Thanksgiving is just days aways from and
Chef Jeff Jackson from Smith's Food and
Drug the sponsors of this segment is
sharing some Thanksgiving turkey tips
check it out
hello everybody I'm Chef Jeff from Smith
it's Thanksgiving and it's a great time
of year to make holiday memories and
Smith has made that possible through a
cool little coloring slash cookbook that
they've come you can see maybe some of
the the characters on there you may have
seen in commercials and things like that
but this is a really great way to get
the kids involved as a coloring book and
there's recipes you can find it in store
online and one of the recipes that it's
in there is how to make a perfect turkey
and that's what I'm going to show you
today just how to do get that done I
have a turkey here that I completely
thought and then I've dried the outside
um so it's ready to go for me what I'm
going to do now is make a compound
butter using spreadable butter that you
can find it in the dairy section at your
local Smith's so I'm going to take a cup
of that or about a half of this
container and then I'm going to add to
that poultry herb blend that I've got
here that I've chopped up and what that
is is that you can find it at the
produce section at your local Smith it
looks like this it's got rosemary it's
got sage and Thyme in it so I've chopped
that up put that in there and then I'm
going to put garlic and what I'm simply
going to do is just go ahead and mix
this up until it all comes together it
takes just a minute or two okay so I've
got my compound butter mixed together
what I'm going to do now is rub it all
over my turkey so I'm going to move my
turkey over to my cutting board and then
what I'm going to do is simply take that
butter with gloved hands if you have
them and just rub that all over the
outside of the turkey you can even put
it on the inside cavity just make sure
the the turkey is covered in this
delicious butter
have a little fun too get your hands
dirty
okay so I've got my butter all spread on
there don't worry about how it looks now
it doesn't look so pretty now but when
it comes out of the oven it's going to
look pretty so take the wings and just
kind of fold them the wing tips around
the back of the bird like that it's
ready to go on my roasting rack I'll
take my gloves off and the most
important thing to do now is to put our
thermometer in there I'd say it takes
about two and a half three and a half
hours but more importantly is
temperature so put the thermometer in
the thickest part of the breast set it
to 160. and then in the oven it's going
to go
until it's done
[Music]
okay we'll let the turkey do its thing
okay guys my turkey came out of the oven
looking awesome
um the butter and all the herbs just
kind of just just melt away and the skin
gets crispy golden brown and looks
fantastic just be sure that you cook it
to the right temperature use that meat
thermometer make sure you get to the
right temperature I say 160 to pull it
because that's like as it rests the
temperature goes up but make sure that
your interior of the thickest part of
the breast gets to 165 that's what
you're mainly worried about but either
way it's fantastic this great this
turkey is missing gravy though right
actually if you look in that if you
download or get yourself a copy of the
of the coloring book cookbook on the
website or again in store it has a
recipe to go ahead and make a gravy on
that same one so I urge you to do that
because your turkey needs gravy right I
wish you guys all the best of
Thanksgiving and all of your holidays
remember it doesn't matter what you make
as long as you're making memories right
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we will see you all
next time bye everyone
visit smithsmoodanddrug.com for more
information JC